is a new season of wokeness beginning
with the NFL the New England Patriots
introducing gerod Mayo as their new head
coach after parting ways with legendary
coach Bill bellich after 24 seasons but
Mayo is already causing controversy
after bringing up racism during his
first press
conference I do see color because I
believe if you don't see color you can't
see racism I want you to be able to go
up to those people and really understand
those people so it goes back to whatever
it is black white yellow it really
doesn't matter but it does matter so we
can try to fix a problem that we all
know we have it's a stark contrast to
what another blackhead coach said about
race last season take a listen to this
from Tampa Bay Buccaneers coach Todd BS
we don't look
at what color we are when we coach
against each other we just know each
other I have a lot of very good white
friends that coach in this league as
well and we coach ball we don't look at
color
interesting the contrast so if you don't
see color does that mean you can't be a
racist Jesse well I see color I mean I
can't deny I I don't see color I look at
Obama and I see that he's half
white but if you have to see color to
see racism I do agree with that
statement but if all you see is color
then all you're going to see is racism
and that's the point I don't think this
coach is like coach Kaepernick Bob Craft
the owner would never do that yeah this
guy was asked a question he's the first
black coach it's a very special day for
him he answered the question perhaps
seeing color is good when it comes to
Recruitment and or hiring to get empathy
and insight but this guy knows the NFL's
a meritocracy if he only sees his color
and he goes 0 and 16 he's done and at
levels like this judge where you're
talking about the highest level of
performance you talking NFL Wall Street
rocket science science performance
trumps everything when that much money
is on the line and Todd Bulls was asked
about him facing off against a black
coach I think it was the Pittsburgh
coach they're both like in the league
for so many years they don't even give
it a second thought they're just going
up against their colleague and you know
the more they focus on Race the less
they're focusing on X's and O's and then
it just becomes a distraction Greg 50 6%
of the NFL is black and I think 25% is
white do you think the players see color
in their coaches probably not but I mean
I empathize because imagine growing up
black and your last name is
Mayo you know
uh but the problem is it's like we we've
gone over this before but if you if you
see color everywhere then you're going
to think racism is everywhere and you
become a servant to single variable
thinking which turns your world into a
very small suffocating space which is
why Joy Reed is always hyperventilating
the the if you look at the research when
we were focused on being a colorblind
Society we actually viewed racism as a
vastly improving issue and once we went
from uh seeing that as as an improvement
to becoming something that is hopeless
it's it's now people see it as a big
problem once we obsessed over it and we
kept in reducing it to every issue
including climate or the Arts or the
move whatever now it's it's like oh my
God we can't do anything about it we
might just give up now you have like
ceremonies that are segregated and that
is seen as not racist right how do that
happen and play dates and play dates I
know I'm not
allowed Piers what say you on this I
look if I was following bill bich as the
coach of the New England Patriots and
idwan six Super Bowls I probably be
getting my excuses in very quickly cuz
it's going to be an impossible act to
follow so now this guy can simply turn
around if it all goes wrong and say well
the the negative coverage is racist um I
think it's a shame I like what the other
black coach said you know because he
kind of removed skin color from the
equation he's and and by doing so you
look at him as someone who got his job
on Merit as I'm sure this guy did right
he obviously he's been at the Patriots a
while he's learned from the best in bich
why make it about race your first press
conference why not just say just judge
me on the content of the character and
performance of me and my players because
as you said you know nearly nearly
two-thirds of the players are black
right you know 60% of Americans are
white should we look at the
disproportionate number of black players
in the NFL and NBA and say it's racist
well of course not we don't look at it
like that and I think it was a shame
that the headlines from his first press
conference it may be as Greg said it
might have been a bit of naive
give him a chance his first big moment
and he was the first black coach there
but it would just be better for him to
say if he just have turned and said you
know what let's forget the color of my
skin just judge me on what my team does
on the pitch I think everyone would have
applauded and moved on and felt good
about it as it is it feels a bit
divisive what's a pitch soccer field
pitch a pitch what do you call them
Fields soccer field ah yeah well if I
play football the way you lot do I call
it a field
too yeah we have manicur pitches you
have rough Fields cuz you're
barbarians we take that as a compliment
I know I know I me a compliment Dana the
Patriots are in need of a quarterback so
does mayo go to Colin Kaepernick well
maybe Tom Brady will come out of
retirement once again no he said they
had that part old white guy Dana I don't
know anything about quarterbacks but I
will say that the media and even the
sports media likes it when they talk
about racism because it get CLI it gets
clicks and so all of these coaches have
to know that this is coming and you're
going to get this question so be
prepared and get media trained and
figure out what you want to say because
the NFL is finally crawled has crawled
itself back from the Kaepernick stuff
right so it's crushing it right now the
ratings are very good remember how bad
it was a few years ago they don't want
any part of this either so if you're a
comm's person for the NFL smarten up get
your people ready good point hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else